we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p there's at
least one viewer who is really not
buying some of Pat's recent coffee
related assertions take a listen to this
hey David I'm just calling in to address
some recent scandals that Pat has been
involved in yeah he claims to only drink
1 to 2 cups of coffee every week logic
can't see how someone who owns a Keurig
a hefty investment mind you only drinks
1 to 2 cups of coffee a week
honestly this is heavily contested in my
friend my friend circles I should say I
really want Pat to address why he and
such a hefty amount of money on a kirok
if he only drinks 1 to 2 cups of coffee
we thank you very much ok but love the
show yeah so part of the confusion here
is Pat drinks 1 or 2 cups of coffee per
day and on a previous episode I
misstated it and said 1 or 2 cups of
coffee per week which i think has caused
some of the confusion but generally the
question is that a Keurig is expensive
and if you have an expensive Keurig you
would really only have that if you're
drinking a lot of coffee first of all is
a Keurig expensive I have no idea what
they cost I think they can range in
price but you know you'll get one for
under $100 so it's another 100 100 and I
have to mention this too I have moved on
to cold brew coffee in the wake of the
scandal ok and what device are you using
for that I don't even know it was a gift
just like the Keurig was I shouldn't
have to face any responsibility for this
and if anything I think that we should
fire this voicemail caller for leading
the investigation against me no but
seriously what kind of coals we're
device you're using I really don't know
you don't know what it was it was a gift
how does it work generally you put like
14 tablespoons of coffee into the
central component okay I use a lot of
coffee yes and then you fill up the rest
of the pitcher with water leave it in
the fridge overnight and just kind of
like how you enter a teabag into a cup
of hot water sure eventually it will
seep out and you'll have coffee by the
morning anyway listen I think it's time
to move on from I'm ready to declare the
coffee scandal dead it's like oh I said
you were having one cup we figured out
it was three and a half cups it's like
yeah fine you had no idea how much
coffee you
have invited months ago you know I think
it's over on the bonus show today we
will be doing discussion and blowback as
a result of the Dave Rubin full show
interview Microsoft is killing mspaint
and 2500 products have suffered shrink
Flay ssin I've talked about shrinks
Latian before and we will talk about
again talk about it again on today's
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership sign up for the bonus show
get instant access and we will talk to
you there